так наприклад ми коли Вікторії в Сумах
були за день 60 обстрілів що казати про
вчорашній Харків це просто жах той
будівля повністю зруйнована що нам
говорити про Херсон що нам говорити про
Запоріжжя сьогодні Миколаїв особливо але
де
про Миколаїв там де взагалі теж коли ми
були були
прильоти вчора і кожен день і все інше
але мене дуже тішить та співпраця Яка є
сьогодні Міністерство освіти і науки
Міністерство внутрішніх справ зокрема в
Державній Службі з надзвичайних ситуацій
керівників департаментів освіти в голів
військових обласних військових
адміністрацій щодо тих темпів підготовки
які сьогодні взагалі ми демонструємо 5
липня це було лише 11%. 11%, які ми
могли так покладаючи руку на серце
сказати що це відносне відносно місце
безпеки на сьогодні ми чітко чітко
принаймні на 15.08 ми вже бачили 41%. 41
в середньому по державі по всіх закладах
освіти якщо брати суто школи то їй вже
48%. і я точно сподіваюсь що ми за 50% з
тими темпами зростання будемо
але при цьому ще дуже важливою знову ж
таки повернусь думку є те що сьогодні
принаймні 50% батьків жорстко виступають
за онлайн навчання
28%
абсолютно готові віддати дитину на
навчання офлайн А є ще 22% за які ми всі
з вами освітяни маємо поборотися мають
поборотися сміттяни мають поборотись
державні службовці маємо поборотися
Міністерство освіти разом з
міністерством внутрішніх справ для того
щоб довести цім 22% батьків Що школа
дійсно є територія безпеки А ми
повертаємось до навчання Ну в принципі
ми в будь-якому випадку повертаємось до
навчання в тому чи іншому форматі
частіше в змішаному
бо це якимось чином дає дітям
соціалізацію Навіть маленькі малесеньке
перебування дві годинки півтори годинки
перебування серед однолітків серед
живого вчителя першачки сядуть за парту
подивляться не в телевізор а все-таки
отримують той дух школи Отже на нас з
вами велика відповідальність Я дуже
дякую колегам з Міністерства охорони
здоров'я які Ну наприклад напередодні
навчального року це завжди було більше
наше з вами наш з вами захід коли ми не
долучали ДСНС просто вона давала акт на
допуск там все але також не було
сьогодні більше звісно дає Міністерство
внутрішніх справ де є Державна служба
надзвичайних ситуацій бо вони фахово
оцінюють безпеку на фізичному рівні ми з
вами тоді оцінювали готовність та
харчоблоків готовність - це нормам
всього іншого було той фрон був трошки
легший Але я впевнений що ти є
згуртованістю яка в нас сьогодні є по
всіх гілках влади між виконавчої влади
між батьківським батьківським
суспільством яке сьогодні точно підказує
ті ключові речі і його треба
прислухатись
повертаємось до навчання Дякую всім
Дякую пане міністри
дійсно потрібно щоб було
безпечне середовище створено і правильно
сказав Сергій Миколайович що створення
безпечного середовища у цьому році це
безпосередньо
проблема якою на сьогоднішній день не
приймаються не лише Міністерство освіти
до вирішення цієї проблеми залишаються і
Міністерство внутрішніх справ і
Міністерства охорони здоров'я і
найбільше Звичайно це наші освітяни на
місцях і громади зараз я хочу запросити
до слова почути
бачення Міністерства внутрішніх справ
щодо безпеки в школі які ми маємо
викликати та можливі варіанти вирішення
запрошую до слова директора Департаменту
моніторингу забезпечення прав людини
Міністерства внутрішніх справ України
Ірина зеленим
дякую доброго дня шановні пане міністри
шановні учасники та учасниці Заходу Я в
першу чергу хочу підкреслити що як
Міністерство внутрішніх справ України
так і нашими органами і підрозділами
спільно з міністерством освіти і науки
України місцевими громадами закладами
освіти безпосередньо здійснюється
комплексна робота щодо формування
безпечного середовища така робота
ведеться системно звісно вже не перший
рік однак сьогодні в умовах військової
агресії Росії проти України така робота
є надважливою і набуває нової
актуальності
активні бойові дії руйнування цивільної
інфраструктури освітньої інфраструктури
постійно загроза ракетних обстрілів
тероризм домінування частини території
України - Це на жаль на превеликий жаль
Це невеликі перелік тих викликів і
загроз з якими ми зараз зіштовхнулися і
які ми
героїчно проти стоїмо Разом з тим як
сказав пан міністр навчальний рік має
розпочатися а школи дійсно мають стати
тією територією безпеки саме тому силами
безпекового сектору здійснюється усі
необхідні заходи спрямовані на
досягнення цієї мети дійсно вже
практично місяць у складі комплексних
комісій представники державної служби
України з Надзвичайних ситуацій і
національної поліції України проводять
обстеження закладів освіти на предмет
готовності до організації навчання та
забезпечення безпеки учасників
освітнього процесу пан міністр вже
зазначив статистичні дані це 48 закладів
освіти дійсно вже готові приймати учнів
не будемо на цьому зупинятися але хочу
підкреслити що під час обстежень саме зі
сторони безпекового сектору вивчаються
питання
інфраструктури безпечної інфраструктури
в першу чергу Звісно це наявність
укритів це обстеження прилеглих
територій на наявність вибухонебезпечних
депутатів це наявність огорожі навколо
території закладу освіти та її стан
Організація охорони закладу освіти мови
йде і про забезпечення камерами
зовнішнього внутрішнього
відеоспостереження це і наявність
тривожної кнопки і забезпечення
турнікетами закладів освіти що
опускаються у разі потреби евакуації
учасників освітнього процесу і багато
інших аспектів враховуються при
проведенні цих обстежень і це
надзвичайно важливо тому що питання
безпеки воно є абсолютно комплексний
мова де І звісно і про безпеку під час
надзвичайних ситуацій але ми завжди
маємо пам'ятати що окрім тих
надзвичайних ситуацій які на превеликий
жаль зараз мають місце ми завжди можемо
або хотілося б щоб цього не було Але
можемо потенційно розуміти що є
небезпеки іншого характеру
Також я хочу зазначити що державною
службою з надзвичайних ситуацій України
розроблена ряд рекомендацій алгоритмів
дій і пам'яток я переконана не буде на
цьому зупинятися детально всі з ними
знайомі і дуже чітко знають
так само хочу щоб інформувати про те що
нашим відомством спільно з міністерством
освіти і науки спільно з місцевими
громадами рядами інших стихолдерів
реалізуються також ряд ініціативи
проектів які спрямовані саме на
створення того безпечного середовища
мова йде про такі ініціативи як класи
безпеки як вихователь безпека або
спеціаліст безпеки в освітньому
середовищі Міна безпека і
ряд інших окремо також хочу користуючись
нагодою поінформувати про те що 15
серпня цього року стартувала навчання
наших вихователів безпеки в освітньому
середовищі це буде 17
вихователів з дев'яти областей України
ми маємо і покладаємо великі надії на
цей на цю ініціативу на цей проект саме
можуть вихователі безпеки
будуть працювати також активно у
співпраці з громадою закладами освіти
над створенням того безпечного
середовища до якого ми прагнемо
звісно у планах є масштабування цього
проекту тому ми розраховуємо на активну
долученість не буду зупинятися детально
вже більш на цьому ми колеги
поінформують вже поетапно по всім цим
нашим ініціативам І на завершення хочу
запевнити що Міністерство внутрішніх
справ України разом з національною
поліцією України державної служби
України з Надзвичайних ситуацій
продовжать докладати максимум зусиль для
того щоб освітній процес був безпечним
щоб він відновився у тих форматах яких
це будуть дозволені Дякую вам
дякую пані Ірино звичайно як сказала
пані Ірина питання безпеки питання
забезпечення безпечного перебування
створення безпечних умов для перебування
дітей - Це одне із основних питань на
сьогоднішній день
не може бути не можемо ми говорити про
безпеку без
не згадавши про охорону здоров'я наших
дітей і у нас сьогодні присутні директор
директора та громадського здоров'я та
профілактики захворювань Міністерства
охорони здоров'я України Олексій
Даниленко та керівник програми
імунізації державної установи центр
громадського здоров'я Міністерства
охорони здоров'я Олександр заїка Я думаю
що питання збереження здоров'я учасників
освітнього процесу нам
повідомлять свою думку Своє бачення
дякую доброго дня колеги
перш за все хочу подякувати за те що ми
маємо таку можливість брати участь
у цьому заході цієї конференції
Як для мене Мої брати цю вперше брати
участь в конференції перебуваючи в
бомбосховищі але на жаль в нас зараз
такі реалії що
ми від цього нікуди не подінемось
на перш за все Хотів би висловити свою
особисту позицію з приводу
взагалі навчання і його початку як
категорично як батько перш за все
підтримую навчання безпосередньо в школі
розуміючи дуже багато батьків
підтримують
навчання не офлайн онлайн мабуть мають
на це право так само але як на мене
все ж таки процес
навчання він повинен бути очним
безпосередньо присутності і в колективі
із педагогами Я не знаю як Для кого коли
перебуваю в колективі педагогічному то
це мабуть ще залишилося із шкільних
часів якось стимулює
особисто мене до дисципліни якоїсь і Я
впевнений що на дітей це так само
впливає тому ми повинні робити все для
того щоб діти мали можливість вчитися
очно
Що ми робимо як Міністерство охорони
здоров'я з приводу того щоб забезпечити
відповідні умови навчання спростити
певні процедури як мінімум на період
воєнного стану Всі ви знаєте
санітарні
санітарне законодавство наше знаєте
санітарні регламенти для дошкільних
навчальних Для навчальних закладів зараз
в нас вже Міністерство юстиції
заіскувало проект наказу про внесення
змін до цих регламентів
найближчим часом вони будуть оприлюднені
в змінах передбачено
деякі положення які спрощують умови
перебування під час воєнного стану під
час
повітряних тривог
є зміни стосовно
заміни денного сну на денний відпочинок
є зміни з приводу він уже передбачено
положення з приводу початку часу
навчання для тих хто навчається
дистанційно за кордоном є зміни з
приводу взагалі процедури дистанційного
навчання тобто Деякі моменти спрощуються
для того щоб діти мали можливість
вчитися і онлайн в тому числі є звісно
ще деякі моменти які нам треба буде
врегулювати але будемо над цим працювати
Я думаю що спільно ми
досягнемо
на Київ
що хотів би ще сказати провід
він ніде не дівся
ми за останні тижні маємо зростання
захворюваності на
39-40%, що тижневого буде ріст
захворювання
карантин у нас продовжено відповідно до
постанови 12:36 до поки що до 31 серпня
цього року вже є проект постанови і
сьогодні його е-е я перед виїздом до вас
дуже візував проект листа на кабінет
міністрів щодо подовження терміну
карантину до
кінця року
мова зараз не йде про впровадження або
посилення
протиепідемічних заходів відповідно до
діючої редакції 1236 протиепідемічні
заходи в нас носять рекомендаційний
характер поки що змін відносно цього не
має але якщо будуть зміни різкі зміни в
захворюваності різке зростання кількості
захворювань і смертей то відповідні
рішення будуть приймати Але не дивлячись
на те що
протиепідемічні заходи носять
рекомендаційний характер я б
рекомендував все ж таки
дотримуватися їх як обов'язкових тому що
після того коли діти повернуться до шкіл
з 1 вересня ми
скоріше за все матимемо зростання
кількості захворювань тому що
знову Діти збираються і педагоги в тому
числі в колектив
скупчення людей більш імовірність
інфікування і так далі тому всі заходи
які передбачені і 12-36 постановою і
постановою головного державного
санітарного лікаря №10 Для навчальних
закладів я б рекомендував дотримуватися
і не читати поки буде скасовано
рекомендаційний характер де за режим
масковий режим Ми повинні думати про
себе зараз і не допускати зростання
захворюваності в майбутньому
далі хотів би подякувати зокрема і
міністру і всім вам за те що ми маємо
такі показники вакцинації серед
педагогів то у нас є взірцем станом на
початок року перед воєнним початком
війни за нашими даними
96 якщо не помиляюсь відсотків отримали
базову вакцинацію протиповіду по бустеру
не можу сказати надіюся що так само
свідомо ви підходите і до отримання
бустеру
перший Бустер У нас вже передбачений
другий бустер для окремої вікової
категорії теж
передбачено тому всіх закликаю
так само з розумінням відноситися до
вакцинації і переконувати в цьому інших
щодо вакцинації окрім ковіду теж Хочу
наголосити на тому щоб ви не забували що
в нас повертаються деякі особливо
небезпечні захворювання
тому рутинна імунізація дітей відповідно
до календаря щеплень Яка зараз в зв'язку
з воєнним станом на жаль бажає бути
кращого
працюємо над тим щоб ці рівні охоплення
збільшувати тому що на станом на зараз
вони в нас край низькі так само дорослі
дифтерія Правець
обов'язково щеплення якщо ви не знаєте
Не пам'ятаєте немає записів даних просто
потрібно щеплюватися і за цим слідкувати
стосовно організації харчування теж
нашим нашими санітарними нормами і
правилами передбачено що
власники можуть Мають право обирати
спосіб харчування або це буде
приготування їжі
харчоблоках школах або це кейтери є
певні ризики під час
під час повітряних тривог щодо того що
наприклад
розпочався процес приготування їжі потім
повітряна тривогах і бомбосховище
технологія порушується або ми втрачаємо
взагалі продукцію або отримуємо ризики
от диптованої продукції отримання
отруєнь серед дітей персоналу і так далі
тут потрібно особливо звертати увагу при
виборі способу організації харчування в
тому числі на це
кейтерінг так само можуть бути порушення
логістичні повітряна тривога невчасно
доведена продукція діти залишаються без
харчування тривалий час тобто тут треба
зважувати всі плюси і мінуси і свідомо
підходити до вибору
е-е
способи організації харчування
ну мабуть все що я хотів сказати
так
звісно в кожному випадку тим більше в
таких деокупованих територіях треба
підходити індивідуально і з розумінням
до тих реалій які я на сьогодні дякую
Дякую вам Олексієм
і як уже зазначалося що я говорила пані
Ірина що створити безпечні умови у
закладі освіти не зможе жодна установа
жоден
керівник громади якщо ми не будемо це
робити тільки спільно тому створення
безпечних умов для здобуття освіти
нашими дітьми це завдання не лише
Міністерства освіти це завдання не лише
місцевої громади це завдання не лише
Міністерства внутрішніх справ це
завдання не лише Міністерства охорони
здоров'я це завдання кожного з нас це
завдання потрібно і можна вирішити лише
спільно і я прошу вам Василя Богдана
начальника управління ювенальної
превенції Національної поліції України
висловити позицію національної поліції
щодо спільного вирішення зазначеної
проблеми
Дякую шановний пане міністр шановні
Учасники конференції школа територія
безпеки це
аксіома вона так є воно так є і воно має
так залишатися Не дивлячись на всі так
скажемо військові процеси які
відбуваються в нашій державі і питання
безпеки та захисту дітей є надзвичайно
актуальними життєво важливим особливо
саме в умовах військової агресії
Російської Федерації протягом
176 днів війни наші діти
почали дивитися на світ зовсім іншими
очима зовсім під іншим кутом вони вже
навчилися відрізняти
сигналізацію від повітряної тривоги Вони
знають як діяти під час таких сигналів
куди бігти Що з собою брати і це на жаль
реалії сьогодення
і загалом під час військової агресії у
нас постраждали понад тисячу дітей
361 дитина на жаль загинула їй 714
отримали поранення
крім того напади на школи та інші
об'єкти цивільної інфраструктури
призвели до того що у нас Майже 2200
закладів освіти пошкоджених серед яких
225 зруйноване повністю І звісно одними
з пріоритетів діяльності національної
поліції залишається створення безпечного
дитячого середовища зокрема і в процесі
отримання знань і ми відштовхувались цих
питаннях саме з
розрахунку співпраці територіальних
громад з управліннями департаментами
освіти оскільки Ми впевнені що тільки
разом ми зможемо досягти в цьому певних
результатів крім присутності ювенальної
поліцейського як відповідного фахівця у
безпекових дитячих питаннях ми у парт з
територіальними громадами запровадили
також такий проект як я впевнений вже ви
про нього чули як поліцейський офіцер
громади
не буду довго зупинятися деталізувати ви
всі в курсі про цей процес хотів би
зазначити що основною перевагою його в
першу чергу є те що він постійно
знаходиться безпосередньо в громаді що
дає йому е-е Ну так скажемо універсальну
змогу бути поряд з закладом освіти і
спільно з ювілейним поліцейським
постійно здійснювати систематично
наголошую це дуже важливо примітивні
заходи саме з дітьми у закладах освіти і
бути так скажемо на відстані витягнути
роки до адміністрації територіальних
громад закладів освіти і насамперед
дітей на цей час вже майже тисячу
поліцейських офіцерів підготовлено а
вони працюють територіальні громадах 548
територіальних громадах майже всіх
регіонах держави
ні наразі відбувається
підбір до 132 вакантних поліцейських
офіцерів громади подальшим кроком
поліції у створення безпечного
освітнього середовища є ініційований
нами у 21-му році пілотний проект
вихователь безпеки спеціаліст безпеки в
освітньому середовищі які впроваджуються
зокрема і завдяки Міністерства освіти і
науки а пані Ірина вже зупинялася щодо
цього проекту не буду повторюватися але
хотів би зазначити що вкрай важливим на
нашу думку є комплексний підхід до
створення безпеки в школах і ми
рухаємось саме за таким напрямком
зовнішнього присутність - це ювенальний
поліцейський поліцейський офіцер громади
і взагалі поліція і внутрішня
присутність це наш пілотний проект
вихователь безпеки і саме тому 16
територіальних громад які приймають
участь у проекти вихователь безпеки в
10-ти вже присутній поліцейський офіцер
громади тобто саме синергія ювенальної
поліції територіальної громади
поліцейського офіцера громади вихователя
безпеки
закладів освіти Департаменту управління
освіти створить унікальну сукупність
безпекових факторів для безпечного
освітнього процесу Ну і поряд з цим в
рамках реалізації програми безпечна
школа національної поліцією
впродовж наступного навчального року на
території держави буде здійснюватись
комплекс превентивних заходів з метою
посилення публічної безпеки і порядку
під час відвідування закладів освіти
здобувачами освіти і посилення
превентивних заходів безпосередньо на
прилеглий території безпосередньо у
заклади освіти внутри крім того хотів би
зазначити що ми повністю відкрити до
співпраці і готовий приєднуватися до
всіх безпекових ініціатив зокрема і щодо
створення безпечного освітнього
середовища дякую
[музика]
і вам дякую
це все залишиться тому що насправді а
воно давало площі результати я на
офіцером але це дійсно ну була допомога
в окремих Ця програма Вона залишиться
так шкільний офіцер про міліції це
проект е-е національної поліції Він
залишиться і спільно з шкільної офіцери
поліції спільно з ювілейною поліцейські
він буде співпрацювати з закладами
освіти і будуть тільки так скажемо
наращувати темпи в цьому напрямі тобто
не переживайте цей проект є і він буде
тільки розвиватися дякую
Дякую за запитання
адміністрації
Дякую за запитання створення так скажемо
безпекових умов в школах в тому числі і
турнікети камери відеоспостереження
рамкови металодетектори і охорони
сигналізації тривожні кнопки все це
досить важливо і ми це питання
відслідковуємо і спочатку
літо так скажемо спочатку Підготовки до
нового навчального року ми вийшли вже до
органів місцевого самоврядування
приблизно з чотирма тисячами пропозицій
щодо встановлення мною зазначених
заходів безпеки і
Дякую тим органам місцевого
самоврядування територіальних громадам
які прислуховуються до наших порад і це
питання розвивається в нужному напрямку
і встановлюється відповідні заходи
безпеки дякую
Дякую пане Василю Як ми бачимо дійсно ми
не єдині у питанні створення безпечних
умов для наших дітей для наших
педагогічних працівників але щоб ми не
робили щоб не зробили батьки все-таки
хвилюються батьки переживають діти
хвилюються вчителі хвилюються і основне
завдання наше напевно донести це до них
щоб вони знали що перебувати у школі
безпечно щоб вони знали що повернутися
до навчання це безпечно і нам у цьому
уже не один рік поспіль допомагають
проводити такі компанії
просвітницькі компанії
розказують батькам розказують дітям наші
колеги наші партнери представництва
юнісеф Україна зараз я надаю слово пані
Світлані кисільовій
Доброго дня всім Я коротенько представлю
ті матеріали які для нового навчального
року в нас є в юнісеф які ми розробляли
спільно з міністерством освіти і науки
спільно з ДСНС і всіма хто секторально
долучений до цього але мабуть мишка не
захоче переключати слайди Давайте так
Тобто ми фокусуємося в новому
навчальному році на кількох складових ми
говоримо про те що важливо підтримувати
ментальне фізичне здоров'я і
психосоціальний розвиток дитини для того
щоб комплексно зрозуміти з якими
проблемами вони пройшли і як ми їх
можемо Підтримати в школі
і юнісеф буде допомагати в трьох
модальностях це в школі там де Ми
створюємо безпечне середовище вдома Де
ми допомагаємо тим дітям які не зможуть
вийти в офлайн в онлайні інструментами і
в громаді Тому що ті хто залишається в
онлайні нам потрібно забезпечити для них
взаємодію так як згадував вже Мура
сьогодні І ми мали невелике опитування
серед батьків воно було репрезентативне
для території України але є похибка в
тому що не всі вибірки зараз скореговані
під кількістю людей які виїхали проте є
чітка тенденція того що батьки готові
повертатися до офлайн навчання проте є
важливий момент що для них це не тільки
те якість освіти яку вони отримують в
закладах але і можливість взаємодіяти з
вчителями чи між собою так і тут те про
що ми говоримо з вами дуже добре
попередні числа і будь ласка вже довго
91% стверджують що вони найбільше
переживають за безпеку тому при
підготовці до школи і В самій школі ну
важливо буде говорити Що ми робимо якщо
ваша дитина повертається в офлайн чому
як ми забезпечуємо це так і це не тільки
про бомбосховище
в офлайні як ми як юнісеф спільно з
партнерами в державному секторі можемо
підтримати окрім того що ми допоможемо і
будуть різні матеріали які ви зможете і
надати батькам і показати дітям різної
вікової категорії окрім інструкцій та
матеріалів з безпеки
ми теж розробили і вони вже є готові
активності для дітей бомбосховищах ми їх
проводили в наших дитячих таборах влітку
і знаємо що добре працюють для різних
вікових категорій ви можете це як
підказку для себе виконати Якщо ви
спускаєтеся з дітьми бомбосховища дуже
прості вправи які допомагають боротися
страхом і з тим емоціями Які діти
відчувають і також
освітньо-інформаційні матеріали змінної
безпеки з психосоціальною підтримки і
здорового харчування про які я трошки
пізніше покажу
в також в тисячі опорних школах Я знаю
що тут є представники регіонів можливо
до вас іще цей лист не прийшов бо ми
працюємо але Ми хочемо підтримати тисячу
опорних шкіл до яких ми надішлимо такі
пакети бокси для бомбосховищ де будуть
основні матеріали які потрібні щоб там
були це і гігієнічні засоби і різні
підручні засоби щоб було дітям комфортно
і допоможемо підготуватись також для
перебування бомбосховищ у зимовий період
якщо опорний заклад певний в громаді не
виходить в офлайн то ми тоді можемо
обговорювати з громадою куди передавати
далі ці бокси окрім того окремі заклади
освіти це або сам заклад або
бомбосховище ми допоможемо відновити
відремонтувати в деяких моментах в тих
регіонах які найбільше постраждали
Якщо говорити про онлайн то окрім
розвитку онлайн-ресурсів які ми
підтримуємо там чи всеукраїнська школа
онлайн чи будь-які інші інструменти в
нас буде інструменти і вебінари для
вчителів для їхньої психосоціальної
підтримки І ми також отримали
роздачу ноутбуків які є для вчителів які
виїхали з території і не мали з собою
жоденних зараз засобів для того щоб
продовжувати навчання
для залучення молоді те що про що ми
говоримо в громадах на базі молодіжних
організацій волонтерських центрів Ми
допомагаємо створити ті середовища де
дитина може прийти і не тільки там
погратися але чогось навчитися якщо ви
знаєте що в ваших регіонах є такі центри
і можливості в громади ми можемо
підтримати і допомогти їм забезпечити
для дітей взаємодією соціалізацію так
тому що вони довго перебували вдома в
карантині то контактуйте з нами Ми з
радістю підтримуємо і допоможемо зробити
ті центри дружніми до дітей і
забезпечити їх матеріалами
і останнє хотіла коротко проговорити про
матеріали Ми розміщуємо все агреговано
на сайті освіта нау.org ми вам вийшли ми
це посилання а також буде на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки коротко про
матеріал про матеріал який вже доступні
підвищення обізнаності змінної безпеки
разом з ДСНС Вам не потрібно нічого
створювати в нас є вже готові можна
наступне так комікси для дітей різних
вікових категорій робочі зошити уроки
для вчителів загадки різні інтерактивні
вправи все що вам потрібно освітянам в
школі для того щоб навчити дітей щоб
дітям інтерактивно зрозуміти як це
відбувається вже є все розроблено будь
ласка користуйтесь завантажуйте вони є
відкритих доступах і ми їх будемо
розсилати по школах які відкриються
наступне будь ласка психосоціальна
підтримка так само вебінари з практиками
онлайн-курси
онлайн інструменти для підтримки
вчителів і матеріали які вже зараз ви
можете наступним будь ласка використати
роздати освітянам так і долучитися до
груп підтримки ми маємо їх як для
підлітків батьків і психологів так само
для освітян із професійними психологами
які допоможуть
освітянам якщо це їм необхідно і третє і
останнє - це
третє остання річ це здорове харчування
гігієна імунізація те про що вже
говорили Міністерство охорони здоров'я
окрім
онлайн-курсів з основи здорового
харчування це для дітей перших-четвертих
класів в нас є інтерактивні уроки які ви
можете використовувати
мультфільми матеріали ігри там наприклад
сортування в які діти дуже добре
залучаються Ми так само їх розійшли Ми в
школу які відкриються офлайн ви можете
їх завантажити або написати в юнісепт
щоб вам їх прислали скільки потрібно ми
також маємо експертні матеріали
питання-відповіді про імунізацію не
тільки рутинна алейку від вакцинації
Тому все що вашим вчителям Може бути
потрібно для того щоб розпочати новий
навчальний рік безпечно в онлайні
офлайні чи на базі якихось таких
закладів в громадах вони вже є готові
якщо ваша область не має таких
матеріалів ви їх не бачили будь ласка
контактуйте з юнісеф ми вам все
надішлемо І ви будете мати ці ресурси
для того щоб не витрачати на них час а
користуватися тим що вже є розроблено
дуже вам дякую
конференція триває сьогодні ви знаєте по
12 локаціям я ще маю бути на трьох прошу
вибачення має ще рухатись на науку на
вищу освіту у нас з вами там працює ще
про в тих освіти але вона працює на
взагалі в іншій області і теж там такий
потужні рухи відбувається у Львові у нас
Олег там нормально йде де
наша Політехніка там приймає участь Я
вдячний кожному з всіх хто долучився до
і серпневої конференції І взагалі доклав
їх зусиль щоб освіта відбулась в перші
місяці війни і намагається зробити
абсолютно все щоб жодна дитина не була
втрачена і відсторонена віддалена
дистанційована від освітнього процесу
прошу вибачення маю їхати з Вірою
брісину їдемо їдемо ще на три локацію
Дуже дякую вам успіхів вам плідної вам
праця гарної дискусії не не стісняйтесь
дуже дякую
Сергій Миколайович раніше запитання одну
секундочку одне запитання пропозиція
Дякуємо вам ну за нагоду зустрітися бо
це найбільша сьогодні цінність коли ми
бачимо один одного і обнімаємось ми
отримали сьогодні хорошу збірку
аналітичну Але у нас з колегами зразу
народилася ідея чи можна зробити другу
частину цієї збірки Де кожен регіон О
пише як він з першого дня війни почав
згуртовувати свою громаду як він
займався мобілізаційними заходами ми от
колеги підтримали у нас є така ідея
24 розділи наш Сергій лондор є присутні
тут ні він поїхав на локацію на іншу
воно доручено це абсолютно тому що це
наш освітній подвиг який зробили героїзм
тих освітян які робили не тільки
організацію освіт процесу а і безпека
волонтерства розміщення
утримання осіб психологічна допомога все
інше евакуація дітей багато хто з нас з
цим займався цим навіть я пам'ятаю як ми
вивозили по Запоріжжю спецконтиненту там
школа яка е-е ну з дітьми з такими не
дуже
ну малолітніми злочинцями їх теж треба
було вивезти там спец умови по вивезунню
то там вже вони стріляли в той
комишувахи там мені здається Там ми ми
встигли може там за годину їх вивести
просто це теж це теж був ну певною
освітній подвиг Дякую всім Мушу їхати
може попросимо юнісепт щоб нам допомогли
Якщо є можливість отаку довідку про
героїзму освітян під час війни отут
другого збірочку якщо ви нам теж дасте
можливість профінансувати їх будемо дуже
вам вдячний
[музика]
Шановні колеги і за дорученням раз уже
ви почали про це говорити А за доручення
міністра ця збірка буде включати досвід
регіонів і всі матеріали сьогодні
Серпневий конференції всі виступи
зрозуміли тому долучаємося Дякую вам
всім до зустрічі
дякуємо
цю нашій локації Ну а Ми продовжуємо
і Як ми знаємо
ми лише
стараннями юнісефу проводиться
інформаційна робота інформаційно робота
проводиться кожним з нас тому що кожен з
нас хоче достукатися до батьків до дітей
до вчителів Кожен з нас хоче забезпечити
дітям
нормальні безпечні умови навчання щоб
вчителі йшли спокійно на роботу щоб діти
з радістю бігли до школи як це було у
довоєнні часи але ми повинні дітей і
батьків про це інформувати і отаку
інформаційну кампанію уже провели наші
колеги це місто Київ Віктор будь ласка
запустіть нам перший ролик і Я запрошую
презентувати свої
[музика]
результати своєї праці директора
Департаменту освіти і науки міста Києва
з класу до укриття
[музика]
при оголошенні повітряної тривоги слухай
уважно вказівки
залишає кабінет разом з іншими Будь
уважним та зі
браним заходь до укриття спокійно без
паніки
дбай про власну безпеку та інших
контролюють свої рухи
швидко та обережно займе
[музика]
місце Не бігай і не кричи
необхідності Звертайся за допомогою до
дорослих
залишай укриття тільки з дозволу вчителя
[музика]
повернувшись до класу нарештійся на
навчання
[музика]
[оплески]
як діяти вранці сьогодні отримують чи
небезпеки на шляху до школи або додому
насамперед разом з батьками обрати
безпечний шлях до школи та зворотної
напрямку
[музика]
визначивши зі шляхом обрати укриття які
дитина зможе використовувати в разі
сигналу то вже треба
[оплески]
[музика]
не звертатися зі шляху
вона з дітьми
не залишатися без необхідності на вулиці
якнайменше часу проводити поза стінами
школи чудові
[музика]
якщо немає можливості дійти до школи
додому під час сигналу повітряної
тривоги
визначений родиною відкриття
обов'язково повідомити батьків та
класного керівника своє місцезнаходження
під час сигналу тривоги Важливо не
залишатися переходом укриття а зайти
всередину
[музика]
торкатися оголених електричних плитків
невідомих предметів це може бути
небезпечним для життя
[оплески]
[музика]
безпека дітей Найбільша цінність
[оплески]
[музика]
шановні
ми з вами Коли почнемо освітній процес
по-перше останній тиждень серпня у нас
це батьківські збори з обов'язковим
ознайомленням з укриттями і відповідно
буде продемонстровано батькам чого ми
від них очікуємо коли ми розробляли
торбинку і шлях від дому до школи або у
зворотньому напряму Ми радилися з
батьками батьки соус нам вносили свої
організації і щоб це сприймалося більш
позитивно Можливо ви бачили торбинку уже
у мене на сторінці там різні думки але
все-таки це є якась єдина рамка яку
можна доповнювати спрощувати або
додавати і далі серія роликів Уже йде
для вчителів які ми будемо застосовувати
щоденно Діти прийшли в школу нагадування
як себе треба поводити в укриті для того
щоб це не говорити постійно вчителеві
Може просто даватися такий ролик як
нагадування вони всі маленькі трошки
більше однієї хвилинки далі Зараз ми
допрацьовуємо як прийти в укриття це
буде ролик навіть для педради для
педагогів щоб їм теж було зрозуміліше і
спокійніше ми всі хвилюємося немає таких
хто в себе впевнений і вважає що все уже
ідеально ні але ми маємо підтримувати
один одного і працювати От для цього ми
робимо такі речі що мені сподобалось
Альона Парфенова подивившись один із цих
роликів зробивши своє зауваження вона
каже ви знаєте ви зуміли зробити
позитивно про негативне про дуже тяжке
Тому це наше надбання рекомендуємо ми
просто свого досвіду воно буде
виставлено абсолютно в вільному доступі
якщо комусь із вас стане нагоді будемо
дуже раді І на чому не наполягаємо
[музика]
і я хочу запитати Світлана ковтуненко є
є на сьогодні ви так це перший заступник
директора Департаменту освіти
Житомирської міської ради Світлана
ковтуненко яка теж хоче поділитися своїм
досвідом на як створюється умови для
безпечного перебування дітей у закладах
освіти міста Житомира
[музика]
я можу сказати Шановні колеги я
представляю житомирщину місто Житомир
маємо 93 заклади з них 46 закладів
дошкільної освіти що чому саме такий
досвід з дошкільної освіти напевно тому
що ми почали в ті складні часи квітня
місяця у нас запрацювало три заклади і
коли нам поставив завдання міський
голова і я кажу що це неможливо зробити
в цих умовах але в принципі було сказано
потрібно щоб працював лікар повинна щоб
виходив на пост поліцейський повинні щоб
були люди які забезпечують
життєдіяльність і охорону міста тому
зрозуміло що потрібно було це робити І в
квітні місяці запропонували три заклади
освіти в різних частинах міста і
зрозуміло Таким чином прийшли діти які
бажають прийшли со сторонню дуже прийшли
з таким знаєте чи здавати чи не здавати
чи як буде тобто дуже багато питань і
всі питання інколи даже в той час
Можливо ми тільки брали собі для того
щоб їх алгоритмувати і зробити все для
того щоб надати відповіді на ті питання
які вже ставилися в квітні місяці можна
сказати тільки одне що починали Ми з 30
дітей у трьох садочках 30 дітей кажу
можливо це не дуже нам вигідно можливо
зібрати їх в один багато було таких от
всяких питань Але
Враховуючи те що ми почали робити
укриття з таким знаєте Ну на свій як ми
бачимо це як ми бачимо долучили і ДСНС і
надзвичайні ситуації Тут я можу сказати
Та й оце в літній період не побачили уже
ваші ролики відео зустрічі да а в квітні
місяці ми з ними просто спілкувалися і
вони нам не давали держпродслужба
охорони здоров'я всі всі служби які
прийшли і надавали нам певні свої
рекомендації вони були професійні і
точні ну тобто ми тільки виконували і в
тому вигляді які вони повинні бути і
коли вже в травні місяці з 5 травня
після якось хоч свят не було але було
якесь такий Затишок після 5 травня нам
прийшлось відкрити більше садочків тому
що уже записувалися записувались люди
вони побачили що є примітивні укриття
найпростіші найпростіші але вони на той
момент були знаєте які такі по всіх
напевно Ну я просто хочу сказати коли
винесли сміття коли все що там було у
нас зберігалося
багато-багато років і треба було його
все просто винести побачити тому що
дійсно площа якась є в певних Коли
побачили що відсутність світло коли таке
нормальне коли труби могли бути і по
половині і з поверху коли земляні погли
коли в деяких закладах які ми побачили
46 закладів треба було тільки 16
закладів відкрити більш-менше по висоті
А всі інші заклади від 07:00 до 1,40 м -
це те що на сьогоднішній день як
будувалися в ті 50-ті роки і до на
сьогоднішній день уже по-іншому Сьогодні
ми прийшли по зразковому від якщо б такі
укриття були Можна було б начинати 100%
процес і я думаю що в цьому закладі коли
батьки прийдуть і побачать яких умовах
будуть знаходиться їхні діти в безпеці
зрозуміло тут дуже великий відсоток але
на що ми звернули увагу на технічні
заходи Це перша технічні заходи які
повинні були це те що я повторюю
освітлення це підйом комунікації це
підлога це
відповідно вентиляція на що сьогодні ще
процес цей не може бути завершений це
питання яке воно було не передбачено Я
думаю що у вас ті ж самі проблеми є і
е-е ці технічні засоби потребують
фінансово вкладень
зрозуміло що міська рада підтримала
підтримали батьки також тому що батьки
приходили без фінансового ресурсу вони
приходили допомагати розгрібати копати
виносити це теж дуже великі
затрати були фізичні але це було подолом
Тому що спільно тільки з батьками можна
зробити те що хочуть батьки а батьки
хочуть щоб їхні діти навчалися і
навчалися якісно тому якщо ми говоримо
про безпеки ви далі виклики які також
стосуються обов'язково звертаємо увагу
на санітарно-гігієнічні вимоги І отут
санітарно-гігієнічні вимоги якщо фільм
запрацює Да ні ну технічно техні просто
вам розкажу
цей Перший в травні місяці які хотіла
показати що було тоді ми ставили
лінолеум
ковровий там доріжки що було потім йшли
дощі потім була спека потім Це все
вологість і так далі І так далі і Ми
зрозуміли що треба що справиться треба
справити з полами Ну просто підлога це
Саме основне яке Потім то і заливні Поли
оці Які можна протирати які можна робити
все щоб там були діти перебували
найбільше покритті у нас за цей період
перебували е-е 5,5 годин Діти від трьох
до п'яти з половиною годин Це те що
дійсно нас спонукало про те що треба
робити і готуватися і до школи не тільки
в садочки сьогодні працюють 36 закладів
освіти сьогодні працюють
два заклади З понеділка відкриваються в
трьох вообще не можна зробити укриття
тому різних ми розділили по різним що
зробили так як і Пані Олена розказувала
алгоритми алгоритми - це для вчителя для
керівника
ми робили трошечки тут безпеку я
обов'язково якщо ви вже дозволите
використати даже ваш ролик тут на
початку вообще унікальний такий дійсно
Він дуже такий ну заводить і можна його
дійсно дивитися і діти його будуть
сприймати
алгоритми по режимним моментам наприклад
садочок який режимний момент прийомка
прийомка зрозуміло зверни тривога
що робити
вихователю що робити іншим працівникам
які
в цьому закладу знаходяться що робити
дітям відповідно зрозуміло Це проробили
далі Коли основний режимний момент це
зрозуміло заняття ігровий літній період
- це оздоровлення - це ігрова діяльність
дітей коли вони приливають приміщенні і
один із других коли Вони прибувають на
прогулянки також і втоми в другому
випадку звучить тривога теж що робити
такі алгоритм дуже важливий тому що він
крім того що промовляється його кожний
бачать і потім повторює Таким чином є
питання з батьками коли і в мене таке
велике питання наприклад по школі і не
тільки по садочкам коли
будуть сьогодні вибирати дистанційну і
очну форму навчання
Скажіть будь ласка а коли батько на
слідуючий день захоче Прийти в школу
якщо він навпаки захоче прийти на
дистанційне навчання це зрозуміло
нормально Коли буде там збільшена
кількість людей а коли він от сьогодні
побачив через 10 днів хоче прийти на
очне навчання Скажіть будь ласка а ми ж
уже склали відповідні розклади ми склали
відповідні класи У нас уже будуть
інша структура по кількості дітей які
знаходяться в тому ж укритті правильно
тому зрозуміло що дані моменти дуже
сьогодні теж хотіла звернутися до
Міністерства освіти щоб нам дали певні
роз'яснення що батьки не тільки від нас
чули Цей голос тому що я розумію що
тарифікацію можна міняти два рази в рік
Ну поки що це ніхто не відміняв Тому
треба сьогодні говорити вибрав вибрав на
півро чи вибрана на чверть чи вибрав Ну
так щоб можна було щоб можна було нам
можливість зробити все щоб ті які
прийдуть очно не було того хаосу це дуже
важливо Це дуже важливо воно буде
пов'язано із безпекою тому що це не буде
ми будем значит сьогодні завтра підуть
Саме ці діти розумієте і чекаємо і
будемо контроль більше здійснювати і
фінансовий там є ресурси всі інші які
повинні бути
Скажіть будь ласка фототешні
я хотіла
технічно не получилося хотіла показати в
якому вигляді Є уже ці укриття але
безпека номер один і сьогодні територія
- це територія безпеки
Світлану Ну я думаю що ви свої
презентації десь поширити і колеги
зможуть їх побачити
так наші представники Міністерства
охорони здоров'я просяться їм потрібно
так що дякую вам за участь До побачення
Ну у нас
залишається небагато небагато часу і
небагато виступаючих зараз Я запрошую до
слова заступника директора Департаменту
начальника управління роботи і закладом
дошкільної та загальної середньої освіти
Департаменту інвестиційної ради аудиту
державної служби якості освіти України
Олена святенка будь ласка
Добрий день шановні Учасники конференції
питання безпеки сьогодні є надважливими
для всіх нас і звичайно на державна
служба якості освіти не стоїть осторонь
ми розробили поради керівнику закладу
освіти щодо формування безпечного
освітнього середовища
під час розробки таких рекомендацій які
вже розміщені на сайті Державної служби
якості освіти Ми
враховували наш досвід проведення
інституційних аудитів закладів загальної
середньої освіти що були проведені в
20-му і 21 роках
враховуючи всі позитивні і негативні
тенденції які ми побачили під час
аудитів і враховуючи виклики сьогодення
ми сформували такі практичні поради а
також ми
розуміли що Міністерство освіти науки
України і ДСНС вже розробили методичні
рекомендації керівникам стосовно
облаштування укриття стосовно створення
безпечного освітнього простору стосовно
зразків документів які мають бути у
керівника закладу загальної середньої
освіти тому наші рекомендації ми
формували шляхом таких от простих кроків
які допоможуть керівнику та які
допоможуть керівнику закладу загальної
середньої освіти
формувати безпечне освітнє середовище
без залучення додаткового фінансування і
додаткових коштів ви бачите зараз на
слайдах можливо дуже швидко вони зараз
прогортуються але ми Радимо наприклад
організувати безпечно та безперешкодне
пересування по школі переглянути
облаштування навчальних кабінетів
розробити заздалегідь шляхи евакуації
розробити чіткі протоколи і алгоритми
безпеки для учнів різного віку правила
поведінки під час повітряних тривог
евакуації перебування в сховищі і в
укритті постійно інформувати учнів про
правила мінної безпеки проводити заходи
Із залученням ДСНС забезпечити
проходження працівниками школи навчання
з надання першої невідкладної допомоги
всіляко підтримувати педагогічних
працівників які бажають проходити або
взагалі організувати проходження
психологічних тренінгів тому що питання
психологічного комфорту і психологічної
безпеки є також дуже важливим в закладі
освіти можуть бути
внутрішнього переміщення особи як серед
учнів так і самі педагогічні працівники
можуть бути внутрішньо переміщеними
особами
Також ми пропонуємо переглянути або
розробити адаптаційні заходи для учнів і
тут же можна вказати і для педагогів які
особливо є внутрішнього переміщеними
особами
наступний слайд я говорила вам про те що
ми враховували наш досвід проведення
інституційних аудитів і на наступний
слайд от якраз він демонструє що ми
побачили за попередні роки в 20-му в
21-му
напрям освітнього середовища вивчається
під час проведення аудитів Отже 25%
учнів не вважають середовище школи
безпечними для себе і у третині шкіл
більше 10% педагогів почувають себе на
комфортно але що є позитивними що в
кожному закладі освіти було розроблено
та реалізувалися план заходів з
попередження булінгу
забезпечення психологічного комфорту
наступний слайд будь ласка
50% закладів загальної середньої освіти
серед тих яких були проведені аудити А
це 308 шкіл в 20-му 308 шкіл за період
20 і 21 рік
достатній рівень освітнього середовища
вільного від будь-яких форм насильства
та дискримінації але все ж таки третина
закладів потребує покращення такого
середовища і в кожній 10-й школі
вакантна посада практичного психолога та
соціального педагога особливо це її
великою проблемою для закладів освіти
сільської місцевості
окремим розділом ми пропонуємо оцінити
керівнику закладу освіти або освітньої
команді оцінити готовність закладу
освіти змінювати причому швидко
змінювати спосіб організації освітнього
процесу
що ми маємо напередодні навчального року
розглянути які питання це гнучкі гнучкі
розклад уроків техні забезпечення
комп'ютери підключення до мережі
Інтернет причому це технічні
забезпечення всіх учасників освітнього
процесу як учнів так і педагогів Ну і
розроблення таких чітких інструкцій
протоколів щодо організації освітнього
процесу в
2022-23 навчальному році і звичайно
інформувати батьків щоб вони були
спокійні в той час коли діти знаходяться
в школі
електронні журнали я думаю що
електронний журнал і платформи які
використовуються в школах це також може
бути під час і очного і дистанційного і
змішаного навчання
окрім того в цих рекомендаціях є окремий
розділ для самопедагогічних працівників
які стосуються підбору різних навчальних
матеріалів для роботи з учнями
під час уроків в період воєнного стану
наступний слайд будь ласка це за
результатами попередньо проведених
аудитів обладнання освітнього простору
звичайно найбільша проблема стосується
підключення до мережі Інтернет з одного
боку є позитивно що майже всі школи
підключені до мережі інтернет Але з
іншої сторони ми бачимо що потужність
цієї мережі недостатньо для організації
або дистанційного або в форматі
змішаного змішаного навчання
напрям освітнє середовище ми вивчаємо
під час інституційного аудиту окрім тих
питань що я зазначила вивчаємо ще
безбар'єрність харчування відсутність
булінгу насильства
комфортно позитивний мікроклімат належне
облаштування навчальних кабінетів і на
наступному слайді ви бачите діаграму я
вам озвучу можливо не так гарно видно
цифри серед усіх закладів освіти в яких
був проведений аудит на рівні
достатньому це було 115 шкіл на рівні
вимагає покращення оцінено освітнє
середовище в 159 школах
низький рівень - Це сім шкіл і 9 мають
високі Тобто ви бачите на тій діаграмі
майже 50 на 50 але все ж таки трохи
більше переважає рівень вимагає
покращення освітнього середовища
за результатами аудитів ми надаємо
рекомендації як розвитку закладу освіти
так і засновникам стосовно
покращення якості освіти освітньої
діяльності але те що стосується саме
напряму освітнє середовище керівник
закладу освіти без засновника на жаль не
може забезпечити тому Шановні колеги в
тих областях де були проведені аудити ви
знаєте що отримували ви такі
рекомендації Зверніть будь ласка саме на
виконання рекомендації по напряму
освітнього середовища і я хочу зазначити
що ми завжди готові долучатися до
проведення
різних тренінгів наразі ми проводимо з
вчителями
тренінг вчитель і учень на дистанційному
навчанні А також наданні методичних
рекомендацій як керівникам школи так і
педагогам тому ми повертаємось до
навчання і сподіваємось що воно в нас
буде очне
Дякую вам Пані Олено і зараз Я запрошую
до слова ще одного нашого це вже
заключний завершаючий нашого спікера -
це доктор педагогічних наук старший
науковий співробітник доцент заступник
директора з наукової роботи інституту
педагогіки на ПН України Микола головка
будь ласка дякую добре Шановні колеги
Сьогодні ми розглянули з вами аспекти
формування безпечного освітнього
середовища зокрема це екологічна безпека
приділили значну увагу бо це власне
фізична безпека наших дітей цей
психологічна безпека бо в цих умовах
дійсно виникає багато чинників
психологічних які впливають на дитину і
Це потрібно враховувати це інформаційна
безпека Я хочу акцентувати увагу на тому
що одним із механізмів на сьогодні
формування безпечного освітнього
середовища є зміст загальної середньої
освіти і
коротенько акцентувати увагу на е-е
здобутку здобутках Національної академії
педагогічних наук України і внесок у
власне цю справу формування безпечного
освітнього середовища Міністерство
освіти і науки у червні ініціювало
створення робочих груп щодо оновлення
змісту навчальних програм і до до цієї
роботи були залучені наші фахівці
зокрема інституту педагогіки інституту
проблем виховання того що і були внесені
зміни і оновлені програми вони вивішені
вже на сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
початкова школа е-е я досліджую світ
відповідно історія громадянська освіта
географія і так далі
мова йде про те що зміст освіти - це те
з чим дитина стикається Власне кажучи
безпосередньо на самих заняттях що може
що можна донести І що можна до дитини в
першу чергу І що можна зробити зміст для
формування безпечного середовища мова
йде про те що наприклад для початкової
школи до інтегрованих курсів таких як я
досліджую світ які з першого по
четвертий клас
вносилися відповідні зміни які
акцентували увагу на інформацію про
безпеку в різних життєвих ситуаціях
дитини інформацію про вміння
розпізнавати ситуації які становлять
загрозу для дитини бо дитина в принципі
особливо в умовах
дистанційного процесу вона звикла що
традиційно на ці аспекти ацетують увагу
дорослі батьки і так далі дитина повинна
їх розпізнавати і це відповідно
враховувати
підозрілі предмети адекватне реагування
на застережувальні написи і так далі
тобто через зміст освіти будемо
намагатися формувати це безпекове
середовище для молодших школярів що
стосується
базової освіти і старшої особливу увагу
приділено
таким предметом як інтегрований курс
досліджує історію суспільства
громадянська освіта історія
всесвітньої історії України мова йде про
те що набувають іншого значення і змісту
сутності такі поняття наприклад як він
на доброчинність волонтерство навіть
науково-технічні винаходи зокрема які
покладені там в основу виготовлення
сучасної зброї і відповідно через
історію через заняття через цей предмет
будемо
намагатися
щоб ці поняття отримали от нові смислі
діти з ними знайомилися далі будь ласка
громадянська освіта теж надзвичайно
важливо в цьому контексті внесені зміни
оскільки це діти старшої школи
знайомляться із
власне захистом прав людини захистом
прав дитини мова йде про те що введено
поняття про спеціальні норми які будуть
застосовуватися у
воєнний час обмеження насильства захисту
жертв війни і так далі убезпечення себе
та свої близьких умовах збройного
конфлікту особливо їм далі будь ласка
географія досить достатньо
оновлення навчальної програми з
географії що може дати оскільки
Під час вивчення географії діти
вчаться орієнтуватися географічному
просторі принаймні в закладі освіти та я
на його території і застосуванням
різноманітних засобів і це надзвичайно
важливо для того щоб ми сформували в
дітей ось ці вміння безпечно
пересуватися територією до укриття
територією школи не тільки школи а
громади і таке інше далі будь ласка
особливо навантаження лягає на предмет
захисту країни от тут ми тут бачили такі
чудові
чудові експозиції да
пропонується внести відповідні зміни які
посилили якраз зокрема в аспекту форму
безпечного середовища мова йде про
цивільний захист уміння навичок
компетентно діяти в надзвичайних зокрема
таких без
ситуаціях коли я небезпека і таке інше
особливе теж навантаження лягає на
природничі предмети фізика хімія
біологія шкільні в принципі в цих
предметах визначення навіть окремі темі
окремі блоки де ми традиційно приділяємо
увагу
збереженню життя здоров'я дитини і
навичок безпечної поведінки в класі
виконання різноманітних дослідів взагалі
безпечного спілкування із навколишнім
середовищем із природою але в цих умовах
коли є
потенційна загроза впливу
шкідливих хімічних речовин або внаслідок
техногенної катастрофи яка не дай Бог
може виникнути або відповідно в іншому
безперечно важливо дітей озна
встановлювати із способами як можна
уникнути негативних впливів це на цьому
слайді зображено така
скріншот із сайту офіційного інституту
педагогіки Національної академії
педагогічних наук Україна на
попередньому складі це були методичні
рекомендації підготовлені
наукової співробітниками відділу
біологічних хімічних фізичної освіти
щодо попередження і ліквідації наслідків
негативного впливу шкідливих хімічних
речовин а на цьому слайді це
запропоновані нашими фахівцями програма
факультативного курсу основи
радіаційно-гігієнічних знань це для
учнів старшої основної старшої школи і
методичні рекомендації для молодших
школярів ознайомлення з основними
радіаційної безпеки що теж є на сьогодні
надзвичайно важливо теж можна
ознайомитися з семи матеріалами тож
Шановні колеги наші фахівці працюють і
надалі будемо намагатися відповідні
зміни у контексті формування безпечного
освітнього середовища вносити надалі вже
в підручники для того щоб максимально
охопити всі аспекти формування
безпечного освітнього середовища в школі
дякую
Дякую пане Миколай Шановні колеги Дякую
всім за участь у роботі нашої локації і
пропоную на завершення послухати
погодитися або не погодитися і з проекту
на рішення нашого сьогоднішнього
засідання
пропоную рішення сьогодні таке визначити
основним напрямком діяльності
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Міністерства охорони здоров'я України
Міністерства внутрішніх справ України
місцевих громад у сфері освіти органів
управління освітою на 2022-23 навчальний
рік створення
безпечного умов перебування учасників
освітньому процесу у закладах освіти для
забезпечення Збереження життя та
здоров'я з урахуванням викликів воєнного
стану в Україні
Дякую всім за увагу Дякую всім за участь
повертаємося до школи
[музика]